We bought all the chicken sandwiches
from every fast food
chain in the US and the UK
to compare the differences.
This is Food Wars.
At a UK McDonald's, chicken
sandwiches come in three sizes.
The mayo chicken, a McChicken
sandwich, and a McCrispy.
McDonald's in the US has four
chicken sandwich options.
The McChicken, the McCrispy,
the McCrispy deluxe,
and the McCrispy spicy deluxe.
The UK KFC options are a
regular chicken sandwich,
a Tower burger, which is the
same but with a hash brown
and some cheese, and a Stacker burger,
which is two chicken patties
with some cheese as well.
KFC options, we currently have two.
The Chicken Little - look at
this little guy, so little -
and the KFC chicken sandwich.
This is part of their Gourmet Kings range.
Whoops.
We have two types of chicken
sandwich at a UK Burger King,
the Chicken Royale or the
steakhouse crispy chicken.
Burger King in the US
also has two chicken sandwich options,
and they are as follows.
I am taking this off.
The Chicken Junior, this guy.
I mean, this looks
exactly like a McChicken.
And the original chicken sandwich,
the only chicken sandwich
we're going to see today
that is shaped like a smartphone.
Popeyes chicken sandwiches in the UK
only come in one size, the
classic chicken sandwich.
Popeyes in the US also has
but one chicken sandwich.
Shake Shack in the UK only has
one size of chicken burger,
the Chicken Shack.
Shake Shack, we haven't done
anything with Shake Shack
in years it feels like, but they're back.
They got a chicken sandwich.
Just on looks, whoa, this
looks ridiculously good.
Jollibee's chicken burgers
come in two sizes in the UK
as a standard or as a double.
Jollibee. I love Jollibee,
and their chicken
sandwiches are very good.
We have their regular chicken
sandwich and the spicy.
Wendy's in the US went all
in on chicken sandwiches.
As you can see, there are nine varieties.
Two, four, six, eight, yeah.
Wendy's only has one size of
chicken sandwich in the UK.
OK, I'm sorry, what sandwich is it again?
And the crispy chicken
sandwich, chicken BLT.
OK, OK, OK, Asiago club,
spicy chicken sandwich.
Wendy's, all right, we get it.
BLT or club?
Spicy ghost pepper.
Bacon. Pretzel. Pub.
Wendy's spicy pretzel.
Then we've got some options
that you won't find in the US.
Two things from a chain called Morley's,
a strip burger and a fillet burger,
and one thing from Nando's,
the grilled chicken burger.
Arby's, which is only available in the US,
has three chicken sandwiches,
starting over here.
They have their crispy chicken sandwich,
they have their bacon Swiss
crispy chicken sandwich,
and they got the Buffalo chicken sandwich.
Chick-fil-A, of course, the original.
You can also get the same
sandwich spicy version.
Raising Cane's, they have, of course,
one chicken sandwich option
on the menu. This is that.
Depending where you are
in the United States,
these are the five
Carl's Jr.-slash-Hardee's
chicken sandwiches.
So here are almost all
of the chicken burgers
you'll find in the UK arranged by price.
The cheapest at this end is
the McDonald's mayo chicken
at just 1 pound 19.
The most expensive is the
Shake Shack Chicken Shack,
coming in at 9 pounds and 35 pence.
For the price of one
Shake Shack Chicken Shack,
you could buy 7.8
McDonald's mayo chickens.
In general, I think it seems like the size
is tracking with the price.
So they do seem a little
bit smaller down this end
and a little bit bigger down this end,
with a couple of exceptions.
I do think the Nando's one
looks a little bit small.
Even the Chicken Shack
does look a bit small,
and that's very expensive.
OK, prices in the US
starting from least expensive
to most expensive.
The least expensive
sandwich, to no surprise,
is the KFC Chicken Little,
which comes in at $2.39.
But let's be honest, this
isn't actually a full sandwich.
I mean, it's almost like a little slider.
The most expensive is the
Carl's Jr. bacon Swiss
chicken sandwich, coming in,
just the sandwich, $11.49.
I think it's interesting that
McDonald's takes up this part.
Wendy's is almost all exactly right here.
Arby's is almost exactly right over here.
I do enjoy Raising Cane's,
but this sandwich should not
be in this percentage of price.
First of all, it's
chicken tender sandwiches.
It's not even like a full chicken patty.
I mean, the Jollibee spicy and regular are
in the lower third.
This is a great sandwich.
Popeyes is here, KFC is right here.
Popeyes and KFC positioned
almost right next to each other, price.
A lot of people, myself included,
would say these might be
the best fast food crispy
chicken sandwiches on the market,
and they're down here, man.
They're like hovering
around McChicken prices.
Here are all the UK chicken
sandwiches ordered by weight.
The lightest option is the
mayo chicken at 120 grams,
and the heaviest is the
KFC Zinger Stacker burger
at 325 grams.
Key takeaways there, a few
of them really dropped down.
For example, the Shake Shack Burger.
The Nando's burger has really plummeted
in terms of price versus weight.
Not a lot of movement at
the bottom end of the table,
which is interesting.
I think even just
visually, like the colors
are quite interesting.
Down the mayo chicken end, the
buns are kind of very dull,
quite a matte finish.
Then the sesame seeds
kind of start to disappear
the higher up you go,
and you head more towards
the kind of brioche bun,
which just looks a little
bit fancier and shinier.
OK, now this is all the
US sandwiches by weight.
Least weight down here,
most weight down there.
OK, once again, the Chicken Little
and the Wendy's crispy
chicken is at the very end
of the smallest. And all the
way down here at the end,
the Wendy's classic Pretzel
Bacon Pub at a hefty
284 grams on this one. Heavy sandwich.
I don't know what you want to
do with this information really.
The one thing I will notice
is the most expensive one,
or the one of the most expensive ones,
is the weight right in the middle.
So certainly not charging by volume.
Shame on you, Carl's Jr.
Popeyes, right?
Popeyes was over here.
Move this way all the way up.
So less in price, more in weight.
Let's go.
And here are all the chicken sandwiches
arranged in order of price by weight.
So the best value in
terms of price by weight
is the McDonald's mayo chicken.
Per 100 grams of burger,
that will cost you just 99 pence.
The most expensive by weight
is the Shake Shack Chicken
Shack. Per 100 grams of burger,
that one will cost you 4 pounds 25.
The Shake Shack burger
is 329% more expensive
than the mayo chicken.
I guess ultimately it comes
down to personal preference
as to whether you want
to pay a little bit more
for what you would hope
to be higher quality
or if you kind of just
want value for money
and quantity over quality.
I think when it comes to fast food,
I kind of just want value for money.
I just want to leave feeling
satisfied with my food
for as little price as possible.
I'm kind of surprised how
low down in the value scale
the Chicken Royale from Burger King
and the standard fillet
burger from KFC ended up.
You're really not getting
that much value for money
when compared to some of these options,
and I don't think the quality
of either of those chains
is necessarily high enough
to justify that price point.
For example, I think the
Jollibee double chicken sandwich,
as well as the Zinger Stacker burger,
you're getting a lot of
food for your money there.
And honestly, these are
really tasty burgers.
So the quality is good, price is good.
I think these ones are what I
would lean towards in general
if I were to order.
This is the order from
best value to worst value.
Coming in at No. 1 ...
... is a Wendy's BLT.
Look at this little guy.
What a deal.
I love the fact that both the Popeyes
and the KFC chicken sandwiches
are arguably the best deal
you can get in the US.
Look at this.
If you're going per 100
grams, the Chicken Little
isn't as good of a deal as
a full chicken sandwich.
I love it.
Glad to see the pretzel
buns are down here.
Because these were the heaviest.
But also comparing it with the price,
you're getting a pretty good deal.
I think from here on, it's like, yeah, OK.
Back here, Jollibee spicy chicken.
Glad to see it.
Great deal.
McChicken's over here, huh?
Raising Cane's.
All right.
I was a little tough on
Raising Cane's before.
Everyone's favorite, Chick-fil-A.
Chick-fil-A here and here.
Really?
This is your favorite restaurant.
We're closed on Sundays for this?
Give me a break.
Shake Shack's over here.
I don't know. I was enticed by its size,
but after running the numbers,
it's not that good of a deal.
Shame on you, Shake Shack.
McDonald's. Even McDonald's isn't safe.
Their McCrispy, all the
way over here for this one?
That's surprising and annoying.
Look at this. Look at this.
Every Carl's Jr., most expensive, right?
They weren't the heaviest. Worst value.
The Carl's Jr. hand-breaded.
Not even the ones with
all the fun stuff on it.
Just a regular hand-breaded sandwich.
Here you go.
It was $10.99 and it weighed 221 grams.
So it's $4.97 per 100 grams.
I know it's a lot of data to throw at you.
Let me just give you the
TL;DR. Too expensive.
So here are all the UK
standard chicken sandwiches.
I'm going to taste them all back to back
and provide you with
my definitive ranking.
Here are the standard chicken sandwiches
at several US fast food chains.
I'm going to try and rank them right now.
McDonald's McCrispy.
I'll give this one a try.
They've gone really heavy on the mayo.
The bun is quite fancy.
It's fancier than you'd normally find
on a McDonald's burger.
It's kind of like a pretzel bun effect.
Nice shiny, decent texture on it.
Not too doughy.
Chicken patty, maybe a little bit thin.
It's a good place to start,
because I think there is room
for improvement there, but
it could be a lot worse.
So starting with down
here, the chicken classic.
I mean, I feel like I'm a bit biased,
because I've been eating these
as long as I can remember.
I'll put it here for now.
I feel like, I mean,
it's good for its value,
but I don't know, it's a little basic.
Now, I don't think I've
had this one before,
the Burger King one.
Similar, I think I like that better.
Yeah, BK.
All right.
Next up we've got the KFC fillet burger.
By the looks of things,
also just mayo and lettuce and chicken.
Overall, it's just lacking
a little bit of something.
It's quite bland.
I think so far, whether it's the chicken,
the breading, or the mayo,
not quite as flavorful as the McCrispy.
So slightly below it.
Come on.
Popeyes chicken sandwiches
has been sitting for a while.
This is the one that everyone
lost their minds about
on the internet.
Everything I'm looking for. Still crispy,
amazing Popeyes flavor.
Love the bun.
Little bit of mayo or sauce on there.
Not too overpowering.
Wow, that's great.
That'll stay in this region.
Big competitor though, KFC.
Ooh, and this one, this
is still really crispy.
All right.
You hear that crunch?
Yeah.
Going in for another bite.
The Burger King Chicken Royale.
I'm tempted to dock points
just because of how
stupid this thing looks.
I've never understood
why they made it long.
I think the ratio is slightly off.
The bun is obviously a long
bun, but it's also quite thick.
So, if you can see that,
you're getting quite a lot
of bread-to-meat ratio.
Yeah, that's the worst one so far.
Wendy's we saw, we'll see later,
but Wendy's had a hundred
freaking sandwiches.
Dry, barely seasoned.
No, that's the worst one.
Was it cheese on this?
No, not very good.
Popeyes chicken sandwich.
Popeyes is a relatively
recent addition to the UK.
We didn't have this until
maybe a year or two ago,
and I will say so far,
people seem to be liking it.
On this one, you get
the chicken, the mayo,
and instead of the
lettuce, you get pickles,
which I think is more
of an American thing,
and one that I enjoy,
because I love pickles.
This is good.
I think we have a leader so far.
The chicken I would say
is thicker and crispier
than any of the three I've tried so far.
Get little, like, crunchy
bits that flake off the edge.
So yeah, I think my
favorite so far, Popeyes.
Arby's, I mean, they got the meats,
and I guess chicken's a meat,
but I don't think about getting
chicken when I go to Arby's.
It's roast beef, right?
No.
Flavorless.
Shake Shack Chicken Shack is up next.
This is the most expensive
of any of the burgers we've tried today.
It looks pretty fancy.
The bun is that classic Shake Shack bun.
I think it's a potato roll.
We have chicken, mayo, and lettuce.
No pickles in this one.
I was wrong.
There are pickles in this one.
The breading on the chicken,
it looked like it was going to be tasty,
but in actuality doesn't
have that much flavor.
And if you actually look at the chicken,
it's quite a thick piece of chicken,
but it's very dry and quite tough.
I think it's probably
worse than the McSpicy.
So I'll tuck it in there.
Here we go.
Let's get everyone
fighting in the comments
with Chick-fil-A.
Never been a Chick-fil-A fan,
and I hope everyone watching
can see what varieties
of chicken sandwiches
you can get at any fast food chain.
Why are you picking this?
What are you doing?
What are you guys doing?
I've never really cared for Chick-fil-A.
It's just the epitome of fine.
I mean this is looking
closer to these ones
than it is to these over here.
Looks really dry.
Got to get the sauce,
got to put sauce on it.
So I got Chick-fil-A sauce.
But I mean the fact that it's like, no,
you have to put sauce on it to enjoy it.
Well, then put the sauce on it.
Why do I got to do it?
And I do really like
the Chick-fil-A sauce.
It's a very good sauce.
I will say what this has
going for it other than these
is that its simplicity makes
it, to me, a little better,
because it's not bogged down
with a lot of, like, soggy
vegetables or sauce or whatever.
When you add in this instance
the Chick-fil-A sauce,
it is better.
So for that, I'm going to put
it, let me put it down here.
It's definitely not as
good as a McChicken.
I just don't see what the big deal is.
I don't.
And everyone's going to flood my comments
with the specialty orders I
have to get with the sauces
and then, no. This is the
sandwiches on the menu.
I got it.
I tasted it. Boring and bland.
Up next we got Jollibee, their
classic chicken sandwich.
Also a relatively new addition to the UK.
Let's give it a try.
Wow.
I think it's the crispiest
chicken we've had so far.
I think it's even crispier
than the Popeyes one.
Could maybe benefit from
a little bit more mayo.
It's just slightly dry is
my main criticism so far.
There's not much to
separate this from Popeyes.
But I think I slightly
prefer the taste of Popeyes,
so I'll tuck it in there.
Yo, Raising Cane's, though.
Chicken tender sandwiches.
Someone's head chef is a 12-year-old boy.
Not a bad idea. Just
stick tenders in a bun,
throw some sauce on here, let's go.
This is good.
Here's why this is smart.
With the tenders, there's
more surface space,
so the crispy-skin-to-chicken ratio
leans more towards the crispy chicken
or the crispy skin,
which just gives it a lot more flavor.
I really like Raising Cane's.
I know I was disappointed when
we put it in the value matrix
that Harry came up with.
But, you don't want to discount taste,
is a very tasty chicken sandwich.
Oh, Raising Cane's,
another one that's famous
for having this Cane sauce
you're supposed to dip it in,
and I didn't even put any
on here. It's still good.
So Chick-fil-A, get out of
here with your extra sauce.
Then we're onto the Wendy's
classic chicken sandwich.
Well, it looks like quite a dry
bun, chicken patty, lettuce,
tomato, and pickles.
Just visually, I had
quite low expectations,
but that's a pretty tasty sandwich.
Not bad.
I'm going to put it
slightly below the McCrispy.
All right, last two.
Shake Shack is great.
I don't usually go there that often,
because I always feel it's a little more
on the expensive side.
And aesthetics alone,
this looks like it would've
been maybe the best one.
It looks like a big piece of chicken.
Yeah, good amount of sauce.
I like the bun.
This looks like a big
chicken sandwich, right?
This is really good.
Yeah.
The flavor of that chicken
is Popeyes- and KFC-level.
I mean, Cane's is cool.
Everything this way has more
of a generic fried chicken flavor,
but from here on, the flavors
are getting more specific,
which I like.
And Shake Shack's, wow.
Then we've got two UK
exclusives to rank as well.
I'm going to start with
the Morley's fillet burger.
This kind of looks like the
platonic ideal chicken burger
that you might find.
Just the lettuce, quite a lot of mayo.
Chicken looks good.
Not the thickest piece of chicken,
but looks pretty well seasoned.
The chicken, I would describe
the texture as leathery.
Quality-wise, you can kind of
tell that the chicken in here
is maybe not quite as good
as some of the other ones.
I think it's down here actually.
Not as bad as the long chicken.
And last, what we've determined
arguably the worst value
for your money,
Carl's Jr. Oh man.
But they're really emphasizing
that this is a hand-breaded.
They're doing it by hand back there.
Let's see how it tastes.
Hello.
This is actually pretty good.
Oh man, I've been dogging
on Carl's Jr. all day.
OK.
All right.
Raising Cane's is better
than this one, but not,
I mean, it's close.
They both have a unique flavor.
Cane's overall has a
better-lasting flavor.
They don't taste exactly
the same, but Carl's Jr.,
your hand-breaded chicken
sandwich is actually pretty good.
Then our final option is the
Nando's grilled chicken burger.
It's some of their
signature grilled chicken
with your chosen spice level.
Leon chose the spiciest one for me.
Thank you.
And it's served on these kind of,
I think it's a Portuguese roll,
which have quite a firm texture to them.
I will say, you can taste
the quality of the chicken
with this one. The ratio is slightly off.
I've always thought this
bun is, like, quite a lot
for the rest of the ingredients.
It's good, but where does it rank?
I think this may upset people,
but I'm actually going to put
it slightly below the McCrispy.
And that is my ranking.
Coming in dead last,
Burger King Chicken Royale.
And I think my favorite is
the Popeyes chicken sandwich.
Going down the ranking from least to best,
says me, in last place we
have, was this Wendy's?
Yeah.
But, of course, the top
two, Popeyes and KFC.
And I want to say, at any given day,
it could be Popeyes one, KFC two.
Those guys are neck and neck,
depending on the KFC
and Popeyes you go to.
Oh my gosh, I almost forgot Jollibee.
This is the standard Jollibee sandwich.
I'll put that between the
McChicken and the Chick-fil-A.
Yeah, not impressed.
It's a lot of chicken I can keep track of.
Now I'm going to talk
about all the US sandwiches
you cannot get in the UK.
Here are all the chicken
sandwiches from the UK
that you won't find in the US,
only we call them chicken burgers.
Firstly, it's the return
of the value king,
it's the mayo chicken.
This is as simple, cheap,
and cheerful as it gets.
It's a slightly oddly shaped,
usually square chicken patty
with some mayo and some lettuce on a bun.
And for a few extra pounds,
you can also add bacon
and have a bacon mayo chicken.
Then we have a linguistic
difference. In the UK,
our spicy version of the chicken sandwich
is called a McSpicy.
You guys call yours a Spicy McCrispy,
which to me seems like an
unnecessary amount of words.
Whatever.
Yarrr.
Then we're onto KFC. In the UK,
instead of having a
spicy chicken sandwich,
we have a Zinger burger.
It's basically the same thing, same patty,
but the breading is a bit more spicy.
I quite like this.
I think generally speaking,
I'll opt for a Zinger burger
over just the classic fillet burger.
Also, do Americans find it weird
that we pronounce it "FILL-it"
burger and not "fill-LAY"?
Because I feel like you
guys will find that weird.
Unless you're talking
about the Filet-O-Fish
from McDonald's, in which
case we say "fill-LAY."
Figure it out.
Our next exclusive from KFC
in the UK is the Tower burger.
So this is the chicken, but
then they add some cheese to it
and a hash brown.
We've also gone for the
Zinger Tower burger here,
which means that you get
this spicy salsa-y sauce
on top as well.
And then we have the exclusive
Zinger Stacker burger.
Now this is our largest
burger that you can find
on a KFC UK menu, and it's,
if I can separate them,
which apparently I can't,
it's just peeled instead.
It's two chicken patties
with cheese between,
and on top, lettuce, spicy mayo,
and some more spicy sauce on top as well.
While we're talking about the KFC ones,
you'll note that on the UK
menu, they're all named a burger
rather than a sandwich.
It's hard to explain exactly
where the linguistic
difference comes from.
I think a lot of it comes
to do with the bread
that your sandwich comes in.
I think generally speaking,
if you have a round bun,
particularly with sesame
seeds on it, in the UK,
what's inside it is just
going to be called a burger.
We actually have quite
a few chicken exclusives
on a UK Burger King menu.
We'll start with this one,
which is the steakhouse crispy chicken.
This is part of their Gourmet Kings menu.
That's how I describe myself.
There's a tomatoey sauce on the bottom,
a crispy chicken patty,
big slice of cheese,
bacon, and then what looks
to be some rocket on top.
For the American audience,
we call arugula rocket.
I've not had this one before.
It was quite expensive.
I think it's got gourmet in the name,
and I think they're using that
to put this at quite a high price point.
It's not bad.
I do think to get this as part of a meal,
you're pushing 10 pounds in the UK.
And I feel like once you've
hit that price point,
just go somewhere else.
Just go to a restaurant, because
you'll get better quality,
fresher food for probably the
same, if not even less, money.
There's a linguistic
difference to point out,
which is that in the UK,
we call our weird long
Burger King chicken burger
a Chicken Royale.
In the UK, we can also
get our Chicken Royale
with bacon and cheese,
or we can get a Californian
barbecue Royale.
So that is the standard
Royale with the chicken,
the lettuce, and the mayo,
but also quite a lot of barbecue sauce,
and also some tomato on there.
Surprisingly, we actually
have a couple of Popeyes
exclusive sandwiches that
you don't have in the US.
Here we have the deluxe chicken sandwich
and the spicy deluxe chicken sandwich.
Now, while a regular Popeye
sandwich is just sauce, chicken,
and pickles, these ones have
sauce, chicken, pickles,
but also lettuce and cheese.
With the standard one, the sauce is mayo,
and on the spicy one,
it's actually the sauce
that changes rather than the chicken,
this one having a spicy mayo instead.
I don't know if adding
a little bit of lettuce
and cheese to something is
enough to qualify it as deluxe.
I think if you're
calling something deluxe,
I'm going to need a little
bit more than that, guys,
but I'll give it a try.
You know what, I'm going to say it.
I think the deluxe sandwiches are worse
than the originals from Popeyes.
I think for the couple of extra pounds
that it's costing you to
add a little bit of cheese
and lettuce to your sandwich,
you're better off without it, honestly.
The next exclusive is actually
a bit surprising to me.
It's this one from Jollibee,
the double chicken sandwich.
It's surprising in the sense
that the UK is the country
of excess here for once.
We're the ones with the
much larger portion.
This is a hefty, hefty sandwich.
We have one exclusive chicken
sandwich from the UK Wendy's,
which is the avocado chicken club.
So you get the chicken patty
with some cheese on top,
and then you have some
mashed avocado, bacon,
lettuce, and tomato.
Not to be outdone, the UK also has
quite a few chicken chains
that you won't find in the US.
And interestingly, our
chicken sandwich culture
is quite different to yours.
Now, in terms of chains,
Nando's is obviously a
pretty iconic chicken joint
over here in the UK.
Now, while you can find some
of these on the East Coast
of the US, over here, they're
in pretty much every city
and town and are kind of
like a foundational part
of the UK culture at this point.
We're now so obsessed
with peri-peri as a flavor
that almost every restaurant
that sells chicken
will have a peri-peri option.
And you've seen lots of other
chains trying to spring up
to capitalize on the popularity,
like Roosters and Pepe's.
Now we can't talk about
British chicken sandwiches
without talking about chicken shops.
Chicken shops are an integral part of UK,
and more specifically London, culture.
The big players are Morley's
and Chicken Cottage,
but there are literally
thousands of independent ones
scattered across the UK.
They're so popular that
people are ripping off
the big chains now.
So you'll see things like
Monley's and Mowley's opening up
with deceptively similar
branding and decor
to the classic Morley's chain.
To put into context just how
popular chicken shops are,
there are currently around
8,000 of them in London.
McDonald's has just 200 locations.
A funny thing is how some of
the independent chicken shops
aren't just ripping off
other ones like Morley's,
but they're trying to rip
off the big chains like KFC.
I think in the UK, people
don't really understand
what fried chicken means when you refer it
to a specific US state.
So I'm sure to Americans
they will know the difference
between Kentucky fried chicken
versus something that was fried elsewhere.
But in the UK, we don't
really have that context.
In the UK, you might walk down the street
and see Ohio fried chicken,
Maryland fried chicken,
or Alaska fried chicken.
As an American, yes, Kentucky
does have a distinct type
of fried chicken.
Popeyes is Louisiana,
other southern states
have their own ways of
making fried chicken.
Yeah, Nashville, hot fried chicken.
That's another one,
which is a city and not a state.
Yes, I realized.
But yeah, Alaska, no, Ohio, no.
Montana, no, no. Montana has no cuisine.
Another thing to point out
is that when it comes to
the big chains like Morley's
and Chicken Cottage, the individual shops
are often franchised.
Leon swears by the
Thornton Heath Morley's.
He's a South London guy, and
he says that's the best one.
If you've been to a better one,
let us know.
Now I'm going to talk
about all the US sandwiches
you cannot get in the
UK. Going to go by chain.
So McDonald's, for instance,
you can get a deluxe
crispy chicken sandwich,
which is just the regular chicken sandwich
with lettuce and tomato, mayo on it.
And then you can also
get the spicy version.
Sauce is a little bit oranger,
which I guess makes it spicier.
Burger King. I saw it
in there. What was it?
You guys called this
the the Burger Royale,
and ours is just the original
crispy chicken sandwich,
sub, sandwich, shaped like that
for seemingly no specific reason.
Yep.
KFC, the Chicken Little,
that's a little guy.
You can also get your Chick-fil-A
sandwich spicy version.
That looks spicier?
It comes in a red bag, because
red is hot, and spicy is hot.
I mean everything at Carl's
Jr. was an exclusive, I think,
because you guys don't even have one.
It just seems like we're kind
of just throwing everything
at the wall and seeing what sticks.
Crispy chicken with bacon.
I feel that Wendy's especially,
Wendy's and Carl's Jr.,
they just are trying to
do variations on a theme,
hoping that will kind of get everyone.
I understand why, but it's
a bit overwhelmed, right?
I mean I don't even know which one to get.
I don't want to bite any of these.
These all look bad.
This whole section here is just like,
throw everything at the
wall and see what sticks.
I don't agree with that strategy, guys.
Just by the looks of all these sandwiches,
the flagship chicken sandwich
at each one of the chains,
I would more go for than any of these.
I don't want any of these.